[Music]
we're back I'm here with Kevin Nealon in
the commercial break you didn't see this
at home
this guy dances up into the crowd and
body surfs over everybody
wow it was fun your body was your body
was undulating stop doing it that's
weird
you're like a dog that I scratch there's
so much to talk about first of all you
and I go way back we've known each other
what like 20 years at least them well
let's see yeah I mentioned when I was a
writer it start out live the 80s you're
a fine writer right out of Harvard yeah
at least that's what you said the
Harvard driving school yeah I cheated a
little bit no no I just got a Harvard by
the way did you really trespassing first
of all congratulations are in order
whatever now where did you get me well
we got married in Italy I just heard her
in me
yeah you went to Harvard me there ask me
I don't heard I heard and because we
just learned he be getting married is
how you say it man yeah so we went to
Italy and went to Lake Como just made
her supposed to be beautiful there yeah
you met Susan right yeah yeah gorgeous
yeah and and it was just me and her we
thought this would be nice a nice little
quiet wedding and you know no big to-do
no you know photographers anything and I
went to Bellagio cute little town on
Lake Como and we get there and we didn't
know but three weeks before we got there
Matt Damon was there looking for chapel
get married in mm-hmm
so we before we got there there's a
little article in the paper that an
American celebrity was coming to get
married they didn't say who it was
though right so they assumed that was
Matt Damon coming so our perfect little
quiet wedding turned into a big
paparazzi thing so that you show up at
the church there's like hundreds of
photographers there we show up at the
town hall and there's a little piazza
out front and there's
- paparazzi there and I guess they're
looking for Matt Damon and I kind of got
by him when inside we went inside and we
got married and as we're getting married
I'm noticing more and more paparazzi you
know coming to the square and I'm
getting nervous because they're gonna be
mad right you know cuz I'm not Matt
Damon yeah and and I'm sweatin you know
and the wedding video looks like I'm
nervous about getting married but I'm
not it's a paparazzi you know I'm
looking out there so we go outside
there's only one way out was like Butch
Cassidy and Sundance Kid you know you
only go out one door right and so we had
to go out that way when we can went out
I apologize as I'm sorry I'm not Matt
Damon
I saw the Italian townspeople but the
paparazzi took pictures anyway and so
the next day we're down by the water and
at a cafe and there's a woman reading
the newspaper next to us and our picture
was on the front page of the local
Italian newspapers said nan Adam Matt
Damon actually I thought you were
kidding cuz I heard about this I thought
you were kidding this is the actual
paper
check this out I love this this is
hilarious yeah
[Applause]
that's right wonderful
what a wonderful memento well let's talk
about okay you're you're married man now
and now you guys you know what's going
on you're thinking about having kids you
got we're actually having that we are
gonna have baby so fast not so fast
it's Matt Damon's okay okay that's very
nice since when do you know the due date
it's gonna be around Valentine's Day and
we um we don't want to know what it is
you know a lot of people like to know
but we don't want to know ever right
we're gonna be changing like this just
figure out yeah okay that's good so you
don't want to know what it is what about
coming up with baby names you gonna try
and start coming up the list of baby
names well you have a couple kids right
that's what I read in the tabloids but
yeah but coming up with names is hard
because you know people can make
nicknames out of every name just about
kids I'd be cruel yeah so I I thought
you know I know that a lot of people
take names from famous poems and things
like that so that's what we're gonna do
we've come up with a name Nantucket
[Laughter]
yeah you're right you're a very bad man
now now do you did you plan to have this
baby uh you don't mean to judge you did
you did plan yeah yeah um but you know I
mean some people actually make a point
they go out of their way to like let's
try and make a baby yeah we do that and
there is a big difference actually you
know when you're having sex to try to
have a baby as opposed to just having
sex you know I mean like when you're
having sex just for the sake of having
sex you know it's it's more like you
know you're a dirty [ __ ] aren't you
yeah please don't make me go through the
whole thing you know when you're having
sex though for the sake of having a baby
it's right it's much different you know
it's it's more like yeah you're dirty
[ __ ] who wants a baby aren't you
[Applause]
you do not get a high five for that
towel before the old leg all right well
what's going on the Emmys huh I'm here
now let's leave the Emmys for later okay
this is the show right here yeah because
I know they tell you guys are nominated
as well for weeds yeah
well get out of that yeah how many
nominations high five man you just
you're so begging for a high five
Elizabeth Perkins that's very good
that's a this is very exciting it's very
exciting and this is it's a very funny
show people love this show
yeah but I want to get back to you and
then we'll get back to weeds and then
back to me what's that with you know
you'll end with me I didn't know this
about you but you wear contact lenses
well the thing is I passed you in the
hall when when you showed up and you
know I saw you like adjusting your
contact lenses I've known you for a long
time I didn't even know you wore them
about 20 years 20 years 20 years yeah
it's you know you get older Conan you
start falling apart like I saw a picture
myself the other day I cannot believe
how big my forehead is getting my eyes
really should be let me show you where I
think my eyes should be actually this is
where my eyes really should be right
about there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh-huh but yeah I got the contacts which
I did not want to do you know I can't
see far and I went to the optometrist
who was very optimistic by the way yeah
nicely done you're not getting a high
five for that so this this dude show me
how to put the contacts in and you know
I don't like the idea of putting
something in my eye
yeah that would be yeah so he sits very
easy just put on your finger like that
it should be upside down it should look
like a bowl and then these two fingers
are very important these are much
stronger than your eyelids so their job
is to hold open the eyelids against
their will because the guy whose job is
to protect the eyeball is closed right
right so um yeah these are like the
bully fingers right here yeah yeah they
work for this finger yes sometimes what
I'll do is I will sneak up along the
side like there's nothing to talk back
like that for a while you can feel it go
limp this one's coming in here like this
you know yeah yeah and and these like
daily contact lens you throw them way at
the end of the day I thought about this
so that you just weren't for the day and
then and then you toss them in rid of
them yeah whether you're wearing mine I
guess you get rid of them no if they
start sticking up the house or what but
right right again it's all timing and
and as I'm getting right about here
sometimes I get nervous you know and it
falls off onto my shirt and I don't know
it cuz I'm like you know and I think
it's still on my finger I think I'm
putting it in my eye and I'm thinking
okay that's not so bad it's not so bad
at the end of the day of course I think
it's still in there so I'm trying to get
it out you know I'm pulling on the
eyeball
so what I do now I own it I don't take
them out at all I just stack them one on
top of each other
I'll go maybe three or four weeks until
there's a big glass knob sticking now I
want to talk about I want to take us all
back trip down memory lane okay what
back in the day when I was working for
you you and Dana Carvey did characters
people love these critters Hans and
Franz Hans and people love who's the
original huh yeah you too you had these
characters and everyone in the country
was doing Hans and Franz is really yeah
it's swept the nation and we wrote a
screenplay together no we did this we
did hey what's that come on
okay open up we wrote a screenplay me
you Dana Carvey and Robert Smith were
smart it was called Hans and Franz the
girlie-man dilemma yeah it was some
music musical yeah yeah surprise they
found work after that so anyway you guys
do this and and what I was curious about
is what did Arnold like you were doing
these characters for a long time before
you ever met Arnold Schwarzenegger
clearly these characters were based on
Arnold Schwarzenegger and you were
really mocking horn honking we're
mocking Arnold then the whole
bodybuilding world yeah and and then one
day you know during you might was
actually when Arnold wanted to come on
the show and be in the sketch we all
looked at each other really
doesn't he know we're making fun of him
you know and then we thought about it
for a while and then we thought well
maybe he's coming on the show to kill us
you know so that day arrived and he came
and they came to get us on the set
remember and they said Arnold's in the
dressing room he wants to see you guys
you know me and Dana in his dressing
room and we became like two school kids
going to the principal's office you know
we started panic and we're blaming each
other you came up with a no I didn't you
didn't you did the girly-man thing I did
not I said not to do the accent but you
want you know so we get to the dressing
room and Maria Shriver was waiting
outside like that
and she's watching us you know as we go
by as like it was it was strange because
we were walking that way she does have
that problems is something wrong real
depth perception uh yeah so we get
inside the dress room in Arnold is in
there and it's full of cigar smoke in
Arnold sitting on this little chair it's
actually regular-sized chirpin he made
it look little cuz he's so big you know
and uh and one he's got the script and
the other hand he's got this fat cigar
and we walk in and he looks up through
the cigar smoke to us and he goes hello
fellas
now how am I supposed to do the accent
he has a good sense of humor and to this
day I don't think he knows my real name
every time he sees me goes hello Franz
how are you and you know for a few years
after that he used Dana and I a lot like
a lot of benefits and fundraisers across
the country sure you worked with him
yeah yeah he you know he wanted us to
dress up like Hans of France and what's
ridiculous ah it's in fly all over the
country you know it's hot sticky I you
know but you can't say no to Arnold well
I think what Arnold tells you to do
something you do yeah we've become as
[ __ ] that's what's happening do what
I say get down give me 50 I want to ask
you really like you I think you do I
think you do a very good job of what you
do you're a good guy
what is it that you do I don't know I'm
here every night people come out I have
a flashlight five nominations it's a
very funny show too
well I got none but the show got five
you didn't have to point that out I was
hoping to get by I was just hoping you
know people would assume that you got
one yeah yeah yeah it's all for the good
of the show it is for the good of the
show yeah and and we're very excited
about it and and people are liking the
show they're tuning in and they're
hearing about it and the second season
really amps it up if you know what I
mean it's really twisted it's uh it's
quite interesting I just wanted to let
you go for a bit and see what you came
up with weeds premieres Monday night at
10:00 on show Tongass 14 yeah okay
and this Monday and Tuesday Kevin's
gonna be performing at Mohegan Sun in
Connecticut is that right that's correct
and you gonna come out to the Emmys oh I
see you there yes I'm going to be there
you know I'm really looking for you yeah
well what's hanging out where will you
be I don't know they'll have me is back
in some my room I'll be getting a
massage yeah are you
for something uh yeah where are shows up
for a couple and you're hosting yeah
interesting I wish you luck yeah yeah
trust me I don't need it this time
Kevin Nealon Conan O'Brien